just really worked hard and worked  himself into an nba a great nba career  yeah i of course won a title here in san  antonio while just hitting the three a  moment ago and  oh curry and one there and fabricio also  fit with that argentinian national team  that won the gold medal as well they had  such great teamwork and chemistry that's  exactly right but this is a uh  this is top of this it's not top 10  that's probably number one  he's going to throw the ball out to the  corner it's covered up so he decides to  flip it off the glass  i mean this is just improv improv at its  best  [Applause]  how do you stop magicians just  incredible how do you stop that you know  oh the free throw bill i'm buying the  lottery tickets oh yeah we all are  what's going on at halftime